in this course daniel bark will teach
you how to code a fully functional
minecraft clone using react javascript
and 3js
daniel is a senior software engineer
from sweden you will create a game that
supports 5 minecraft block types it will
include moving jumping switching and
placing blocks saving and more you will
learn about mini react concepts such as
ustay use effect use ref and custom
hooks for state management and you'll be
able to apply the principles to create
other 3d games in javascript alright so
let's get on with the tutorial and to
begin with let's have an overview of the
steps we're going to take in this
tutorial to build a minecraft clone
so first we'll look through the code
that we're starting out with and the
packages that we're going to use
then we'll add our first 3d element
which is a skybox that will wrap the
entire world
we need some images that will be used as
textures on the ground and on the cubes
and next up we'll use a plane as the
ground
and our player is going to interact with
that ground
and so the player is going to get a
first person view will
mount a camera to a sphere
and that will feel like a first person
game
then we need to have some gravity we
need to make sure that the player cannot
fall through the ground and when you
jump you should fall back to the ground
and so on
we need some movement to go back and
forward and to the sides
and then we need some state management
because we need to keep track of all the
cubes in the world so you need to be
able to add and remove cubes in a global
state
so we need to keep track of that
and then we also need to keep track of
what type of cube the player want to add
to the world
so we also need some type of ui that
indicates what cube texture is active
it would also be nice if we can save our
world so we don't have to start from
scratch every time we come to the app so
we'll implement a button to store the
world in the local storage
and also to
reset the world if we want to start over
we'll have a reset button for that
and in the end
we should build ourselves something fun
like a house or
we'll see what we come up with all right
so let's look through the code that
we're starting with so we have a
package.json
so we have react3 fiber the the main
package and then we're going to use some
nice functions from canon and dry
we have react we have three
we have a way to generate ids and we
have the state manager zoo stand now
let's jump to the components folder is
empty right now but we will populate it
inside images we have
small images like this we have dirt
glass grass
logs and wood
and i already created a javascript file
that just imports these images and then
exports them in an object like this
let's go to the index
so here
not much is going on quite standard
we have
an index.css file
with not much in it i just added some
helper classes and we'll probably add
some more later on and inside the app
here we have
just a div that says outside canvas and
then we have canvas from reactory fiber
and we have nothing inside the canvas
right now so we see a text here that is
outside the canvas and the rest of the
screen is covered by the canvas alright
so we are done with looking through the
boilerplate
so onwards towards the sky
so the sky we will import from
let's see if we get some help here
sky from react 3 dry
and let's see if something happened
yes we got a sky
so for now we can remove this div that
says outside canvas what i wanted to
show with that is that you can add
normal html as long as it's outside of
the canvas because if i move this into
the canvas
we get some errors because
react3 fiber doesn't know what to do
with the div it has all kinds of other
primitives it can render like meshes and
geometries and so on
but it cannot handle divs but we can
place them outside and then we can mix
the 3d stuff and the normal html stuff
so i'll remove outside canvas for now
so we get a full view of the 3d content
here
for on the sky we can set
sun position
and that takes an array
of xyz
so i'll do
120 or something
it doesn't matter too much but now we
see that the sky got a bit brighter and
i cannot really look at the
any other part of the sky because the
camera is now static
and so we can adjust the sun position
later if we're not happy with it but at
least now we have a
sky in the day and not an evening sky
like it was before
so i think we'll leave the sky like this
for now and jump onwards to the next
step alright so let's prepare our images
and turn them into 3js textures
so first i'm going to change actually
this images file
so that we can
destructure them when we import them
directly
so i will clean it up like this
let's create a new file
and call it
textures
so then we can import
from
images
so what we need to do here is create
textures so let's start with the dirt
texture
so we need to import
from 3js
the texture
loader
so we say new
texture loader and we give it the dirt
image
so we just repeat this
there we go and
we create a separate texture also for
the ground
even though we're going to use the same
image so we'll call that ground texture
and uses the grass image
so now we want to export these
there we go
so now we have a file that exports the
textures
so i think we can cross off textures and
images
so our next step in the list is to work
with the ground
so let's before we create the ground
let's add a few things in here
let's add an ambient light so that is a
light that will
light up every
3d surface
and that one takes a prop
intensity
so let's do one 0.5
and before we
include the ground
we need to add a physics container
because we're going to use a hook from
canon to create our plane that will be
the ground
and that needs to be within a physics
boundary
so the physics from canon
and inside here is where we can create
the ground
so let's create that component now
ground
okay
so here to create our ground plane we're
going to use a hook from canon
called use plane
so this plane will give us an array
where the
reference comes first and that is a
reference that we will place on the mesh
that we
let canon control
so use plane
so it takes a callback function that
returns an object
so here we can set some properties of
this plane like rotation and position
and so on
so we'll do rotation and here we have an
array of three
and position also
an array of three
so now we're going to return some
elements here
so
we will take a mesh
first we will reference this mesh so
we'll set ref is ref
and then we have the geometry so we'll
have a
plane buffer geometry
and we'll attach
this as a geometry
and here we can set the size of the
plane
with the args prop
so since it since it is a plane it has
two dimensions
so we'll set it 100 by 100
and we also need to add a material here
so we'll do a mesh
standard material
and this should attach
as a material
and here is where we want to add a
texture
but first we can just set a color
let's do hot pink
all right so if we look at the browser
now we have something hot pink that is
covering
the entire
screen
so we don't want to have color hot pink
here we want to attach the ground
texture
so let's import
the ground
texture
so we just say
map is
ground texture
okay so we got an error because we
forgot one step in the texture loader
we need to call it and then
call the load function
okay so we instantiate a texture loader
and on that we call the load function
for each image that's important to
remember
so now we can continue debugging this
okay so now we have a new texture here
so we
as we can see it doesn't really look
like
the
the grass image which has
these small pixels on it
so what i suspect is happening now is
that the image is being stretched out
so we want this texture to be repeating
we want this small image to repeat over
and over
so we can do ground texture
dot
wrap s
and we'll do repeat wrapping and import
that from three and the same for
t
and then we'll do repeat dot set
and we'll set this to the same as our
size
hundred hundred
there we go so now we have it repeating
but as we can see the it looks very
blurry
and that has to do with
how
the texture is being stretched and how
essentially how the rendering engine
figures out how to display these colors
so
with this setting it's like smearing
them
and we
can change that if we do ground texture
dot
mag filter
nearest filter instead
so let's see what happens now
that looks much better now it looks
pixelated as it should
so our next step would be
to flatten or lay down the ground
because right now the ground is standing
up
so we can play with this rotation here
so i will rotate the x-axis
and we want to rotate it 90 degrees but
in radians
so 2 pi would be 360 degrees
which means that 1 pi is 180 degrees
and half of a pi is 90 degrees
so i will do math dot pi divided by 2 to
rotate it 90 degrees
and it might be that we're seeing it
from behind now
so i will flip it 180 degrees
so
it folded over maybe so that we
can no longer see it with the camera
so let's do it a little bit less
okay there we go so now we can see that
it lays
down
but not completely 90 degrees
but for now we can keep it like this for
a while we can see that
it's almost correct
because once we can move the camera
around it's going to be easier for us to
to flip it back then because then we
will add gravity and we will fall down
onto the ground but let's keep it like
this just that we at least at least can
see that we have the ground there
alright so we have the ground
let's start to work on the player
so our player needs to have a camera
so we can the structure
camera
from
a hook
called use
three
so that hook is from reactory fiber
so we also need some type of geometry to
represent the player the geometry that
can collide with other geometries and so
on
so for that we can use a sphere so this
will be similar to what we did to the
plane for the ground
so we'll do use
sphere
and we call
we call use sphere
and it takes a function
that returns back an object
so here we can set
mass we'll set that to one
we'll set type to be
dynamic
and we'll return a mesh
and attach the ref
and then let's add
our player
all right
so we we should have a player now
so the next thing
so we won't see that anything change yet
so we need
somewhere to store the position of our
player
so let's create a variable called
position
and we'll do a reference
and it has x y z coordinates so we'll do
zero zero zero
to begin with
now we will call the use frame hook
so this hook will run on every frame
so what we want to do now is attach the
camera to this
position that we're going to connect to
our player
so what we can do is that we can take
the camera
which is from use three
and we take the position
and we copy
and we pass in a new
vector 3
and this vector we give
position dot current
and we give it the x and then we do the
same for y and set
position.current.1 which is y
and position dot current
two
so now we should have a camera that
follows
this reference to a position here
okay we can set the console log here
just to see that
our frame is running
okay so we see that
we no longer see the ground and we have
frame console login here so we can see
that it runs on every frame
so let's remove this so
we did something to the camera at least
that is good so if we uncomment this
line
we should see the ground again
and we do
so that's good
so we were able to move the camera we
copy it to this position
every frame
so our next step is
to have this position
follow the position of this sphere
because this sphere will be affected by
physics and gravity
so we can do a use effect
and this
use
effect
will need to re-run every time the
sphere changes position
so we can
take out element number two here from u
sphere which is the api
an api towards the sphere
so we'll say that
rerun this effect every time the sphere
api position changes
and what we want to do when the position
changes
we want
api dot position dot subscribe
and subscribe takes a call back
where we get
call it p and we'll say
position dot
current is equal to p
so p is a triplet
so it will look
like this
so now we have a sphere that is
connected to this reference
or let's say this reference follows the
sphere
and
we can get the camera to follow this
reference so our goal is to get this
camera to follow the sphere
okay so now i added back the camera
so we can see that something
happens we get ejected i don't know if
we may be colliding with the ground
and then to handle that collision we
just get ejected
if i change the set value here
so if i do 10 and i reload i land on the
ground but because remember what what
technical depth we had from the ground
we didn't flatten it to 90 degrees
properly
so now would be a good time to fix that
so like i said to to rotate 90 degrees
that is half of a pie
so now we flatten the ground out
so we fly up and then we land on the
ground we have
taken the camera
we
glue the camera to our position
reference
and then we subscribe to
api position changes of the sphere
so we have a rift that tracks the sphere
and then we glue the camera to a
reference hopefully that makes sense so
we need to do
similar things to the velocity
so let's copy
this position code here
i will call it
call this vel
and here we track api dot velocity
api dot velocity
so here we get v
and we'll set
vel dot current
to v
so now we have
a reference of the velocity
that subscribes to the velocity of the
sphere
okay so let's fix this catapult effect
thing
so what i suspect happens is that when
the sphere is inside of the ground plane
they that state cannot exist so we just
get
flung out so that there's no collision
anymore
so we need to lift up the sphere a bit
so let's try five
so now we
start from above
the plane and then we fall down to it
so let's see how close we can get
so if we put one we seem to be standing
on the ground as we start so that's
great
let's see if we can actually trigger
some movement on the sphere
so we
have the api
so we can do api dot velocity dot
set
so here we can give it the x y and z
velocities
so we can do 0 1 0 then we should be
constantly lifted upwards
so we'll do something similar to this
when we implement jumping because then
we want to set velocity upwards but just
for a short while so it so you fall back
down so it's a normal jump
all right so i think before we can move
with before we can
move forward pun intended with the
player
we should make a hook for the keyboard
inputs so that we can register different
key presses
that we're going to use to control this
sphere that is the player
so let's
add this
to our to-do list
keyboard
inputs
so the player
is not yet done
we'll move to the keyboard inputs first
so the keyboard input is actually a hook
so let's do a hooks folder
and we'll call it use
keyboard
export const use
keyboard
so we'll need to have some state here to
keep track of what keys are pressed
so we'll do
we call it
movement
set
movement
use state
so let's set up this initial state
right so we need to map out all the keys
and call them things that we understand
so one action is move forward
move backward we also have move left
and move
right we have jump
and then we have
texture one
[Music]
two three
four five i think that should be
all the
now that we have textures we should
maybe call it actions so now we need to
have a use effect
and inside here we do document dot add
event listener
listen for key down
then
we need to create some functions to
handle this
key up
and since we're adding
event listeners we also need to return a
function that removes them
otherwise we will add endless
event listeners
handle key down
we wrap this in the use callback
so inside here we get
the key
down event so let's create some helper
function to determine
what key maps to what
so we'll do
function
action
by key
so here we get a key
key map
key action map
so here we say key
here we need to type it as they
as they are called in the key event so
key w like this
we'll call it move forward and we have
space
for jump
and then we have
digit one
and now we can say what texture it
corresponds to we'll say it's dirt
and the last one is
log
so now we mapped out what keys belongs
to what actions
and then we just return
key action map
with key of course we need to check
so that only we only react to the keys
that we are listening for
action by key e dot code
so now we can do
set
movement and of course we need to
preserve the previous state
so we
spread the previous date and then we set
we can do action equals action by key
e dot code
now we can just say
if action
action
is true
and this is now called
set action
actions
okay so
it will be very similar for a handle key
up
just that we set this to false
so here we need to handle key down and
handle key up
and then we just return
the actions
let's try this hook from the player
component
i'll do like this so we'll just see
those that are true
key and value and we
return
those that have true
all right so now we should be able to
see in the console log when we press
these different keys that we are looking
for
okay so we have no actions when we start
that's good so now i press w
because i'm not getting anything so
let's debug
let's see if we are here
yes we get the keyboard event action by
key action by key is a function not a
map
so this should fix that and same thing
here
so i'm pressing w
s
a d
jump
spacebar
and the digits one two three four five
okay so we have everything working so
now we can react to these actions
and control the movement of the sphere
by looking at what key process we're
doing so we can cross off the keyboard
inputs alright so let's control the
player using the keyboard inputs and i
think an easy one to start with
is the jumping
because
this requires some vector math
so it will be a little bit
tricky but i think we'll manage it
so first we can look at
if
actions dot
jump
that means that we are jumping
we can reuse this code
here we can for the x we just
keep the value
and for said we'll just keep the value
and here
this is
a constant that will use for
the jumping so let's store it
jump
jump
force
let's try 10.
jump
jump force
okay
let's try it out
spacebar
alright so we achieved the jump
it felt a little bit too high
and also
we can jump indefinitely which is wrong
so first let's fix the jump height let's
try three
yeah that's better
i'll try four for now
so we need to do another if check here
if we can jump again and one easy way
of
eliminating all these extra jumps
is that we make sure that our y
velocity is zero make sure that we're
not moving up and down because whenever
we are moving up and down it means that
we are falling through the sky or
already jumped and we are on our way up
so we need to make sure
that
the velocity in the y direction is
really close to zero
so let's do
since we we care about positive and
negative we can do
absolute value
and we have it on velocity dot
current
it's vel right
current one
should be smaller than zero dot
let's do zero dot
zero five maybe
okay so let's try
good we can still jump
i'm pressing it
continuously but we we're only allowed
to jump once we've landed
there's one bug that we should fix
and that is that we can
we can jump if we hit right in the
moment when we're actually slowing down
from going up to going down again
so it's uh
the the velocity there becomes almost
zero
at a certain frame
so if i can time that frame
you can see that i can jump two times in
a row
but we'll leave it like that
for now so we can start to think about
how we move
in a direction and
the tricky part about it is that
later on we will be able to turn around
so w will always take us in the camera
direction
so we need one vector to represent what
direction we are facing
another vector for the forwards and
backwards speed and the other one for
this
side speed
so let's create those vectors
one
direction vector
vector three
and
[Music]
call it front
vector
also a vector 3
and a side vector
so the front vector
it's this said axis here that will
determine
us going forwards and backwards
so both the move forward and move
backwards should affect this
force here
so one way of doing it is
we check
actions dot move backwards
and we set it to one
if we're moving backwards
or zero
and then we subtract
the same thing
but for moving forward
so if we press them at the same time
they cancel out we could actually
destructure
here
move four backwards move forward move
right move left jump
then we can clean this up
like this
and like this
all right so we have this one one or
zero and this one one or zero and if
they are both one
they cancel out which is a good thing
because if you
go forward and then you start to hold
backwards also
then you should stop right that's what
we see in games
so then we've taken care of the front
vector
so let's do something similar for the
side vector
so we'll copy this
so now we're not moving in the set
direction anymore
i think this should be the
x direction
and here it's moved
left
and here it's move right
so we get the same behavior there if
you're holding both at the same time
you should go nowhere
there we go
so now we're going to do some
calculations
and we'll we will originate from the
direction vector so the direction
dot
subtract
vectors
and those
vectors are the front vector and the
side vector
and then we'll chain on some more
operations
we normalize
and then we
multiply scalar
and here we need to
determine how fast we want to go
so let's
also make a
variable for that or as constant
we'll try 4 for speed as well
so we'll multiply the speed
and then finally
we apply euler
and this is where we
get
the correct facing direction from the
camera
so we have a reference to the camera and
its rotation
so this is where we make sure that the
front and side vectors are correct
in relation to the camera
so now we can take this direction vector
and apply it to the sphere
so api dot velocity
dot set
and then we
do the direction dot x
direction dot y
and
direction.
but that's not completely true because
the y axis is not controlled by these
front and side vectors this is just for
moving backwards and forwards and to the
sides so the y should actually stay
the same
so the vel dot current
one
so that should be enough in the best of
worlds we would be able to move at this
point
see if we need to refresh
all right i think we're missing the new
keyword here
for the vectors
there we go
all right so we have a typo here
okay so let's try i'm pressing forward
all right so forward is working
backward is working
now we'll try backwards and forwards at
the same time
and it stops that's great let's try left
and right at the same time and i let go
of left
alright
so that seems to be working
so we cannot yet test that it will be
still correct when we turn the camera
that we will do once we
once we build out the
the pointer lock controls
where we can control the camera with the
mouse alright so i think
we are done with the player for now
let's move forwards with the first
person view
so we'll create a component
fpv
this one is actually quite simple
because we get a lot of help from
react 3 fiber here
ok so we need of course to connect this
to the
camera so we need use
three
where we can get the camera
okay so we return
pointer lock controls
args is
camera
destruction gl here
passing that
as gl dom element
fpv
from fpv
and just render it
all right so when i click here now
it should lock the camera
to how i move the mouse
so now i can look around
so now we can see that if i'm facing
left i can move straight ahead and if i
turn a bit
i can still move straight ahead so our
player movement seemed to work fine
and the pointer lock controls seem to
work as well
there's one thing we should do with the
first person view is that we should add
a small cursor to
the middle of the screen so outside of
the canvas let's add a div
class name
cursor
and let's put just a plus there and
let's position it absolute
and we're going to center this on the
screen so let's make a class called
centered
so this is position absolute so we do
top
fifty percent
left
fifty percent
we need to add a transform
translate
minus fifty
and minus 50
so that is just because if we
if we center it 50 50
without doing this transform translate
then
it will not actually be in the middle
because
i think i can show you this background
hot pink if we make this bigger
we see that it is in fact centered but
if we don't have this translate
this is what will happen the top left
corner of the square will be in the
center
so what we're adjusting for with 50 is
50
of the width and height of the square
so then it would move to the middle
but this one doesn't need to be big at
all so we'll remove these two
that looks good and then remove the
background
so move the the color styling to cursor
there we go
now we have a marker to indicate the
center of where we are watching great i
think we are done with
the player for now so we will cross out
first person view we're also done with
gravity
and we are done with the movement our
next item on the agenda is to add a
state manager
we can add a hook called use store that
keeps track of the game state let's
create our hook
use store
so we'll need
create from
sue stand
use
store
we can wrap this in create
and we get a setter method here as an
input parameter so we will return an
object so we call create we pass it a
function that returns an object
so in this object we can declare our
state
so we need to keep track of a texture
and we can default the texture to
dirt we need to keep track of the cubes
that the player is going to be able to
place
so we can just default that to an array
and now we're going to declare our
methods that you can use to interact
with the state so we'll of course have
add cube remove cube you need to be able
to set the texture and for later we want
to be able to save the world reset world
these are all the operations that we
need to support
in our
store so when we add a cube
all we need to know is
where to place it
because the texture we already know
since we are in the store so when when
someone calls add cube
we need to call set
and in set we pass it a callback
function and we get back
the previous state so here we can return
an object so here we just want to affect
the cubes which is an array
so we spread in
the previous
cubes
and then
at the end we add a new cube and
every cube needs to have
a key
and then we can use nano id for that
we have a position
that we get from xyz that's being passed
in and then we have the texture
which we can get from priv
so that should be all it takes for us to
add a cube but before we
do that we need a way to render cubes so
i suggest that we leave the store like
this for now with just a method of
adding cubes and then we create the
component to render a cube
and then we can start to
render them out we can actually
initialize the state
with one cube just for debugging let's
do one one one so now we always have
one cube initially that we can
quickly see
if when we start to rendering the cubes
if they come out
so i suggest i suggest that we leave the
store like this before we finish the
rest of the store functions
and then start to working on rendering
our first cube so let's add a new
component
before we create the cube we should have
a
component that is taking care of
rendering all the cubes essentially
consuming the store and mapping out the
cubes
so we'll make a component called cubes
so we need
definitely to have
used the use store
from hooks
so our use door hook
we can
we get the state back and then we can
return an array where we can place
different things from the state in
whatever order we want
so we want state dot cubes
so then the first element here will be
the cubes so if we do console
log
cubes we can return nothing here let's
add cubes
cubes
so since the player needs to be able to
stand on the cubes the cubes need to be
within the physics
slide it like that
okay so we consoled out the cubes and
this is our debugging cube that we added
a dirt cube on position one one one so
now we can start working on
mapping out those cubes so we return
here we're going to use the cube
component
so let's create that one first
since we're doing a mapping we need to
use the key
which is something that we have on the
cube already
we have key we have x y zed
texture so here we can use the key this
is actually position
so we receive position
and texture
so to create the cube we're going to use
the
the canon use
box
hook
so we'll set type is
static
and we have the position from the
incoming prop
so here we return a mesh
and to the mesh we connect the ref
here we need a box
buffer geometry
and we also need
a mesh standard material
attach
as
geometry
color is hot pink
do we have a cube anywhere okay so i see
we called it position in the store
and here we're destruction
position
so we need to call it puss here
oh
okay
so the reason i couldn't find the cube
was because i was standing on it i feel
very stupid now
that's good so let's play around with
these values
see if we can get get it up in the air
all right
so there we have our first cube
right so we have the cube standing on
the ground
so now let's fix
the texture of the cube
so let's pass in the texture
in the store we just call it
dirt and in textures we call it dirt
texture
so let's do texture plus
texture
so we import all the textures as
textures
and then
we map it by
the texture in the store plus texture
and then we get our active texture
then we can do map
active texture
and remove the color
there we go we get the dirt texture on
the cube
let's move it a bit closer to us
so as we can see it doesn't
look so good so we need to do the same
treatment we did to the grass to every
cube texture so we'll test it with dirt
dirt texture
mag filter
nearest filter
let's see if that helped yeah now it
looks good and pixelated and not
smooshed
let's do it to ground texture in here as
well since we are already here and then
we don't have to do it
in here let's
move these out as well
there we go so now we fixed it for all
the textures inside of the texture file
instead to keep our components more
clean i was thinking to maybe keep this
in ground because it correlates to the
size of it
so we'll keep it here
so now we should be able to add a second
cube with another texture
i will pick another position
texture
would
all right so now we can render cubes
with different textures and this one
looks nice as well since it's been fixed
alright so now we have a way of
rendering cubes once they are added to
the store all right so we have the
basics of the state management and we
have the cube's
basics as well
something that is missing in this list
is
adding
cubes
so one way of adding a cube is to click
the
ground so let's open the ground
so we need to get the add cube
method from use store
add cube
and return an array with state dot add
cube all right so we had have the add
cube
method
uh but we need to figure out the x y and
z coordinates to
uh to pass to this function so let's add
an on click to this mesh
let's do e dot stop propagation
so that the click cannot be passed
through the ground so on the event we
have something called e dot point
so we want to get x y and z
we can do object
dot
values
from e dot point
so let's stop here to check out what
happens when we click the ground
so we have e
let's look at point
so we have
a vector 3.
so we just want to get
the values of this vector we don't want
to pass the whole object
so if we do object.values we just get
these three values and we destructure
them out here
so if we hover
the xy and said we see that we do in
fact get the values here as you saw
there are
a lot of decimals here we want
the cubes to end up on fixed location
according to this grid that we can see
here in full numbers
so we need to round this so we need to
do a mapping of these values
and return math math.c
of the value
and then we should be able to call
addcube with x y and zed
right so let's try this out
let's reload and we click the ground
and we do get a cube
so as we can see
the seal function made it
round up so let's try with floor instead
so as we can see i think we should try
moving the ground
down
by half a unit and see if that will make
the cubes
lay flat on the ground so let's try that
so now that we fix the ground
we can go back to seal here
math.seal and when i click the ground we
actually get cubes added pretty cool
so now let's lower these default cubes
or we can actually remove these default
cubes now that we have a way of adding
cues for real okay so we handle the case
where you click the ground and you want
to add a cube but what about when you
click the surface of a cube to add a
cube next to it
okay so let's handle the clicking of
cubes so we can copy this
state call here because we want to do
the same
inside of cube
but we also want to have remove cube
later on so let's add that straight away
so my plan is that if you hold in the
modifier key and click then
you can remove cubes as well
so let's add an on click
we stop propagation
so here we need to handle a few things
a cube has six sides and the side that
you actually click
needs to get another cube
next to it
so we'll create a variable clicked face
and a face of a cube actually has
two triangular shapes that covers the
face so it's not a full square it's two
triangles
that together cover the square face
so instead of six faces it has 12 faces
but that is pretty
easy to fix
so we can just take take e dot phase
index
and divide this by two
and then we will be in the range between
0 and 5 instead of 0 and 11.
and we will of course need to math dot
floor it
because
there's no
0.5 phase index so now clicked face
should be between 0 and 5. so let's
console log
face
click face
so let's add a cube
here phase four
phase one
phase five
phase zero
top is phase two and the bottom should
be phase three then
so now we just need to write if
statements to cover all these clicked
faces
so if it's zero
and cube so we have a ref to the box
that has a position so we can do
x y set
from
ref
current position so we can pass in x y
set
and then we need to on one of them
maybe subtract one to the x
and for another face we need to do x
plus one but it's a little bit of
guesswork to figure out what phase is
what direction if you understand what i
mean
one two three four five
six
so something like that this will most
likely be wrong all right so we add a
cube we click one face
so here we see that it was
the opposite
all right so now we have logging as well
so if i click this face we see that it
was four and the cube was added on the
other side
so clicked phase four
just needs to flip
and then let's flip this one
if i click
this face
that was
phase one and that was also flipped
so
this should probably minus one
and maybe plus one here
let's try the top
so
phase two nothing happened so i'm
suspecting that there's a cube
underneath
so this should probably be plus one and
this should be minus one
so let's try again to click the top yeah
now that was correct
so i think we might have it
nice
now we can click a cube to add another
cube next to it so now now it starts to
become fun
so we can return if we are done with the
operation
so now we can handle the removal of
cubes
if e dot alt key
remove cube
x y set
and return
and of course we haven't implemented the
remove cube function yet
so what we can do just to try it
quickly is to just console.log here
x
y zed
x y said
remove
all right so i'm holding down the alt
key and i'm clicking it and we get a
call to remove cube
with x y said so that's great
so now we can implement the remove cube
function
so we can
borrow some code
from ad cube
we'll still call set
but instead of
adding to this array
we can take pre-dot
cubes dot filter
cube or we keep all the cubes where
x
y and z are not
equal to the xyz being passed in so with
the structure
x y and z
from the cube
then we return
x not equal to x
y not equal to y
and said
not equal to set
so let's see if we can filter out the
cube that we're clicking on
let's add a few
so here we need to say cube
cube dot pulse all right let's try again
so add a few cubes
and then alt key
and they were all removed i think the
issue is that this should be or
because if any coordinate is not correct
it's not the the right box to filter out
so let's try again
there we go
one cube being removed at a time great
now we can remove cubes
great progress
alright so we are done with adding cubes
and removing cubes
so let's continue with
the cube type selector so we should
create some ui that indicates
what
selections there are and what is
currently active so let's create a
component
texture
selector
and this one will not be a three
component this will just be html and
this one should just be visible when
we're actually changing the texture so
we need some state here
let's determine if it's visible right
now or not
we'll default it to false
we need to get
the texture from
from the store
active texture
state and we get
an array back where we take state dot
we just call it texture
texture
so let's
call create a use effect that runs
whenever the active texture changes
active texture
so if the active texture changes we want
to have this texture selector visible
for like two seconds and then we want it
to disappear
so we need a visibility timeout
that is set timeout
for two seconds
so after two seconds we want to set
visible false
and immediately we want to set visible
true
and then we need to clear the timeout
clear timeout visibility
like this
so we only want to show something is if
visible is true
so let's do class name
absolute and
centered
so now we we also need to handle so that
the texture is actually changed
when we press the digits
actions from use keyboard
so in the store we have a set texture
method
so let's finish that we take a texture
we call set
we don't care about the previous
we just want to set
texture based on the incoming texture so
let's look at use keyboard
we have texture one to five
this is what we want to
dig out here
so let's do a use effect again
that will run for
texture 1 texture
2.
if texture won so now we need the set
texture from the store
set texture
dirt
okay we'll call this
dirt
grass
glass
wood and
log
so the actions will now contain props
that are the actual names of the
textures
so we'll call it pressed texture
so if any of these textures are true
then that texture will be the pressed
texture and then we can do
if
pressed texture
set texture
to pressed texture
let's see pressed
pressed texture
so let's see if it works
if i press
one all right let's debug
so if i press one there to be true so
that's great
so it works correctly in use keyboard
and in the texture selector let's
console log
dirt
let's see if we can get there to be one
so one thing what we must do is add the
texture selector to our app before we
started looking for console logs in it
so let's add it here
texture
all right so we get dirt falls
we saw it there and as i press one
we got dirt true
and texture selector appears for two
seconds and then gets removed
so it looks very promising after texture
all right so here we have our textures
as
booleans
so let's create a mapping
that will set
the prop which is the name of the
texture
that will map from the name to the
booleans
so then we can do
object dot entries
find
key value so we want to find
a texture where the value is true if we
have such a pressed texture we'll take
the value
from that all right
so we get
five booleans here
and
we put them in a mapping
so we'll get dirt falls grass falls
maybe glass true
and if glass is true we will find the
true texture
store that in press texture so if we
found a pressed texture
we get
the key of that
by taking
the first
element in that tuple
so let's see if it actually worked
gr pressed grass pressed dirt pressed
wood
and press log so now i press glass
so this is the glass cube
pressing dirt
and i get a dirt cube
so cool we have
a way of selecting
different textures just using the
keyboard i know what happened with this
cube
but let's continue building the ui
to show the actual selections
so we already have a list of images
with these so let's import those images
okay so let's create a mapping here
images
so we keep the name that they are called
in the store
to the actual image
so we need to loop this
in a map here images
i will do object dot entries
images so here we get
key and
source image
so we can return an image
image tag
source is
source
key is
okay
and now we need to check
which one is the active one
and that we can do by adding a class
name
so here we can do
k
equals
active texture if that is true if that
is true we add active
otherwise
nothing
and let's have an alt prop
put the
the name of the texture all right so
let's see if anything happened so when i
change the texture now
here we have an error this should be
an array
so now let's see oh we got it
so when i change texture
the texture selector appears
so we should just make it bigger
let's add a class
texture
select
so we can do transform
scale
10
it should be select door
there we go that's bigger
let's do maybe five
and then let's handle
the active also
so if we have an image.active there
let's do a border
of
two pixels solid
red
so let's see if we can see which one is
active
yes we can
okay so we
between the four and the five we have
the wrong digits
so that is probably because i typed them
in the wrong order here
all right now they work correctly
all right let's see all our cues
we have
wood or log we have wood
we have glass
we have grass and we have dirt
really nice
let's remove this console log all right
so our cube type selector is done
the next thing on the agenda would be to
save the world in local storage so that
is something that we can do inside of
our store so let's create some helper
functions
to talk to the local storage so what we
want to store
in the local storage is an array
so we need to do json parse and json
stringify
to talk to the local storage
so let's call create a helper function
get local storage
so we take in a key and we return
json.parse
window local storage
get item of key
so all we're doing is json parsing what
we get from local storage
and let's do
a similar function
with
set local storage we take in a key
and of course the value that we want to
set
and then we do json stringify
set item
and then we set
we pass the key
actually this json string if i should be
just wrapping the value
value
right so now we have our helper
functions
so when we first create
this date we want to do get local
storage
and we can just make up a key here we'll
call it cubes
so we'll either get something
or it will be empty
so we'll fall back to the empty array so
now we can implement
these two functions let's start with
just resetting the world
that would just be set
and then we just set the cubes
to be
empty ray
like that that should reset the world
and then we have say world so we call
set just to get the current state
and inside here we just call set local
storage the key was cubes
and we store
red dot cubes
so we don't need a load world function
because
that happens when we just reload the
page
but we we also need to create some
buttons on the ui for this let's create
a component called menu
so we want to access save world and
reset world
from use
store
so
state
reset world all right
so let's create some ui
last name of
menu
and
absolute
we need save
and we need
reset
on
click
save
world
reset world all right
let's import menu
so let's see where we have our menu
we have it but it's down there so we
need to style it so it becomes in the
top
so we'll do top
10 pixels
left
10 pixels
there we have them
all right so let's
try them out
we'll place a few cubes of different
types
all right we have a nice line here
let's save it
so now it should be in local storage we
can verify that application
local storage we have cubes and there we
have the cubes
so now when i reload the page
we have any cubes oh here they are
really cool so now we can persist it of
course we can also reset
but they are still in local storage so
if i just reload
the cubes
will be there alright we are done with
saving the world in local storage but we
have one more thing that would be nice
to have
hover state on cubes
i think it would be nice if when the
cursor hovers the cube that they become
a bit darker so that you indicate what
cube you're actually hovering on right
let's keep track if a
cube is hovered
set is hovered
we use state
from react
false we can add some pointer events
here on
pointer
move
and we take the event
stop propagation
set
is hovered true
and then we just do the same for
on pointer out
and now we need to adjust
the appearance based on the hover
so let's add color here
is hovered
let's make it gray if they're hovered we
make them gray otherwise we keep them
white
but one thing that would be nice is if
the glass cube would actually be a bit
transparent so we add
transparent
true to all the cubes
and then we do opacity
active texture
equals
glass then we do
0.5
otherwise
we do one and this should be
just texture
all right so there we have transparent
glass and maybe it's a bit too
transparent
let's do 0.6
really nice
very cool
all right so we're getting close to
being able to build that house and of
course transparent glass is a must for
building houses
so you can watch outside
all right i will quickly finish this
house
just to check it off the list
should probably have a door
all right we're inside the house
i think we can check it off the list
all right we can say actually right now
that we have fixed everything on our
to-do list and even some more things
that we had to add as we went on
for those of you that got this far kudos
to you it's quite a long project if you
want to submit pull requests to this
project feel free i will look at them
and probably pull in
many of them so thank you so much
everyone that watched i hope you learned
a thing or two about
building 3d things on the web and i hope
you got inspired to try out to build
something on your own so please keep
watching free code camp continue to
learn and also you can check out
my channel if you should want to bye now
thanks a lot for watching